c'est bientôt la 27e édition de la fête
de la science la manifestation débute ce
samedi et va durer jusqu'au 14 octobre
on en parle ce soir avec olivier morand
directeur de centre sciences et
coordinateur régional de la fête de la
science
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour
cette nouvelle édition ce sont les idées
reçues qui ont été choisi comme fil
conducteur
pourquoi ce thème alors tout simplement
parce que bon c'est un choix de la
ministre
frédéric vidal de pouvoir permettre
notamment aux acteurs de la fête de la
science principalement les scientifiques
de permettre à ces acteurs de préciser
auprès du public que une opinion n'est
pas un fait scientifique et donc les
scientifiques eux pour travailler ont
besoin d'éléments factuels et que
souvent très souvent notamment à l'heure
actuelle avec internet il est très
facile de trouver des avis des opinions
sur le sur le net et que justement la
fête de la science les acteurs sont là
pour essayer de préciser au public qu'il
faut pouvoir vérifier les faits aller
chercher ses sources d'information et
c'est notamment des travaux qui ont été
menés aussi par des élèves dans des
lycées alors justement de manière très
concrète comment la science peut lutter
contre ce qu'on appelle l'effet que news
les fausses informations
c'est un des objets notamment de la fête
de la science et de pouvoir permettre
aux visiteurs au public d'aller
rencontrer directement des scientifiques
de discuter avec eux de les questionner
sur un certain nombre de sujets sujets
qui peuvent être aussi bien des sujets
de santé des sujets sur les matériaux
des sujets sur tout un ensemble de
thématiques de les questionner et puis
d'aller à l'encontre de ses actions que
ça soit les conférences des expositions
mais bien sur les stands qui sont
présentés lors des villages des sciences
sur l'ensemble de la région ce week-end
quelles sont les animations qui nous
seront proposés sur la région centrale
de loire toutes sortes d'animations
alors il y à aussi bien des visites de
laboratoires sur l'université d'orléans
par exemple oublie parfois qu'il ya des
laboratoires dans les universités mais
il ya également tout un ensemble de
stands d'animations expérimental qui
sont réalisés sur les différents
villages des sciences régionaux et puis
aussi bien des animations ludiques parce
que c'est souvent aussi par la
manipulation par le jeu qu'on peut aussi
de véhiculer un certain nombre
d'expériences
et d'idées et de thématiques auprès du
public et notamment du jeune public et
du jeune public je vous le disais tout à
l'heure ça fait 27 ans que la fête de la
science existe comment est ce que vous
avez vu évoluer en 27 ans cet événement
cet événement il a évolué notamment
parce que les acteurs sont de plus en
plus nombreux on compte plus de 300
actions cette année en région centre sur
répartis sur à peu près 80 lieux et donc
on a de plus en plus d'acteurs qui se
mobilisent qu'ils renouvellent leur
thématique c'est souvent le plus
difficile c'est trouver une nouvelle
thématique thématiques scientifiques
notamment qui est développé par un
laboratoire de recherche un programme de
recherche et donc c'est l'occasion pour
ces scientifiques de proposer ses
nouvelles thématiques de recherche au
public merci beaucoup olivier morand
d'être venu nous parler de cette 27e
fête de la science qui commence donc à
la salle ont su samedi dès qu'il a
commencé samedi dernier pardonnez moi
qui va durer jusqu'au 14 octobre dans
toute la france et dans toute la région
centre merci merci